the deegeu Salam alaikum peace be with
you thank you for tuning in to the Deen
show I'm Eddie your host and some time
back we had a special get all of our
guests our special but this is a unique
individual who came on and shared his
story and it's really spread all over
the world many people got to benefit
from it it's about a a gentleman our
brother dr. Jill Dirk's who finished at
the Harvard Divinity School and then his
journey on how he came to Islam we want
to check in with him to see how he's
been housed his life been going since
then and we're going to be back with him
here on the D show so sit tight don't go
nowhere it comes to you the truth and
the attribute of the one who created you
that he's one and alone running this
universe that he doesn't become former
he doesn't die he doesn't eat and go to
the bathroom this is not God problem
yeah is this it doesn't make sense
who was Jesus worshipping emphasis is
recorded in the gospel despite all of
the other issues about the Gospels we
put those aside to say it's mentioned
there's Jesus
from hunger I said I'm like oh and peace
be with you well I like um so my mother
dr. Gerald Dirk's how you been oh pretty
good I've been fine
it's good to have you here in the Dean
show again good to be back now about a
year ago around this time you were with
us and we were very delighted to have
you come on and share your experience
your journey to Islam which Islam simply
means to acquire peace to by submitting
to the one God to the will of God and so
many people where we're on so many we're
in a few satellite channels now and not
only do we broadcast here in Chicago on
the local TV station but now thank God
we're on several different satellite
channels so many people have gotten to
hear and benefit from your story so if
you can just kind of recap for those who
didn't get to hear your interview you
can go to the Dean show comm but just
kind of bring us up to speed and and the
rest of the people of how you in short
you know end up making this turn towards
Islam and then we're going to come back
to a typical Christian okay well you
know I started out as an undergraduate
at Harvard and then went into the
Harvard Divinity School for three years
during my Master of Divinity and I was
in fact an ordained minister in the
United Methodist Church yes at the level
of deacon but upon entering seminary
especially a good seminary one is
exposed to a lot of information that the
average Christian layman is never going
to be exposed to and that information
has to do with the reliability of the
biblical texts alternate versions of the
texts that are out there etc and changes
that we know have been made in the text
sometimes even knowing when and where
those changes were made and why they
were made so a person comes through this
experience and
it shakes where one thought they were
going it shakes the foundation upon
which they thought they were standing
and so as a matter of fact upon my
graduation from seminary even though I
was now in an ordained minister I was
when I called an atypical Christian a
typical one word a typical to find that
they heard me say it but now you said it
again what does that mean a typical for
me and a typical yeah a typical being
one word Christian was when I was I
didn't believe in the divinity of Jesus
Christ peace be upon him I didn't
believe in the concept of the Trinity
but I certainly did believe that there
was one and only one God so that's what
I would define this as being an atypical
Christian did you ever speak in tongues
no no some people would make this as a
proof that you know Christianity Lilya
yeah so what are you what do you think
about this just to get off the topic for
a second like if somebody mentions is
someone sent me an email they said well
this might be a proof that Christianity
is a truth because you got people you
know it's a phenomenon people speaking
in tongues by the power of God so much
arrestee come on my boat Orion Omaha
City well they're they're speaking
something something but I have yet to
hear of anyone tape recording a session
and and qualified linguists looking at
it and saying oh I recognize that
language yeah as far as I know it's
always unrecognizable so whatever okay
so anyway so let's go back now so you
became an atypical Christian so even
before seminary school you were
preaching teaching the Bible yes yeah
and now you went to seminary school you
were exposed to textual criticism
textual criticism form give shape to
form criticism yeah early a early church
history yeah etc and you went deep into
this and then I remember you saying in
our last interview that you were
listening to some of the preachers
preach and teach some of the things that
you knew they weren't in the Bible well
yeah I knew they weren't legitimate
things to be being taught
give us an example of that oh I I can
recall one one minister one Sunday
morning who was basically doing a give
me money sermon yeah give me money
summer yeah you know give the donate
money to the tree sermon or basically he
began to really stretch some biblical
concepts about giving yeah so tell us
now you became an atypical Christian and
you believed in one God like many people
they believe in one God they don't
believe in the confusion that's out
there a lot of these man-made things and
you were kind of stuck up on for awhile
just being away from Islam and
everything else so how was your life
then at that moment when you were just a
typical Christian you know my wife and I
tried to live our lives and what we
believed to be a moral and ethical bike
yeah you know every now and then I'd go
to church because I thought it was an
important family thing to do when
something I did very often and I can say
I often you know ended up gritting my
teeth and what I was hearing yeah being
said but you know I continued to pray
did a lot of praying directly to God oh
absolutely not to any prophet st. or
just to the career left to God
you know I continued studying I he would
frequent the local seminary bookstore
and see what they had in it cetera and
read up on some of the later the latest
archaeological finds of Israel so now
you're an atypical Christian now you
came to accepting Islam how did that
happen again well that started primarily
by having contact with some Muslims in
the Denver Colorado area yeah by
observing their lives and fine
we recognizing they were living their
lives a very moral and ethical way quite
at variance with the society around them
and and asking myself okay now where
were these people drawing their
religious strength from yeah and so I
began to read English translation of the
Quran began to read books on Islam by
Western authors and the more I read the
more I ended up saying to myself well
you know there's nothing here with which
I disagree yeah you know this is
basically what I believe now some people
get hung up on the Arabic and you
haven't it now you know address a
certain way and you know do certain
things that maybe you aren't accustomed
to so did you have did you become an
Arab now because you became absolutely
not and in fact you know this is
nonsense yeah what you saying
you know as far as the dress code goes
Islam prescribes that you dress modestly
yeah and there are some specific
requirements in terms of that and terms
of for a meal anyway you know things
going down at least to the man at least
above the the navel but there's no
prescription that says you wear a thumb
and a CUFI or you know a sari or any
other non-western clothing you know you
certainly wear your own Western clothing
just modest clothing so you're still in
the American oh absolutely yeah so you
don't have to give up now you don't
become a Pakistani or you don't become
Arab absolutely not absolutely that you
just become one who submitted to the
will of God sure sure that makes a lot
of sense when I take a break and with
right back with more here on the
deanship death and the day of judgment
the mercy of Allah these are the things
that finally made me realize there is no
time to delay anymore I wanted to take
my Shahada right there
the essence of spirituality is to become
more sincere to lost planet without a
bunch of latekka so it is very very
scary but it brings you back to reality
there is a life which is everlasting of
you and you have to make a conscious
decision of which a group of people do
you want to be people have having over
the people of hell
back here on the Dean show with dr.
Gerald Dirk's and people can go to the
Dean show calm to see your full story on
how you came to Islam now we really want
to encourage people to read the verbatim
Word of God the Quran yes and before we
go into that and dwell upon that you
were reading the Bible and you were
finding that was there Islam in the
Bible was it calling you to acquire
peace by submitting to the one God and
this is what led you finally to Islam
was it was it reading the Bible did that
help whatsoever oh absolutely it out
absolutely reading the Bible help and I
think anyone who reads the Bible with an
open mind and reads it afresh in other
words don't read the Bible but through
the lens of what you were taught in
Sunday school this is important read the
Bible of fresh what does it actually say
yeah this is the key now with the Quran
many people think that okay is the same
thing you got multiple versions of the
Quran like you do it the by how many
versions of the Bible do you have action
well usually when we see versions what
we're really talking about is different
translations the difference however is
that when we talk about different
translations of the Bible the different
translators go back to different sources
there are different manuscripts King
James version of the Bible goes back to
fairly late Greek sources the immense
it's not very old something like the New
Revised Standard Version of the Bible
goes back to very early textual sources
to derive its translation now having
said that it is the case that there are
different Bibles different Bibles yes so
would that be like in one Bible you have
one verse taken out and another one put
in or some things in one Bible like the
whole books whole books out so wouldn't
have constitute a new different version
well yeah but usually I can say when
people say different versions of the
Bible they're really talking about
different translations but in reality
the if we look just at the Old Testament
yeah
the Protestant Old Testament does not
have all of the information in it that
the Roman Catholic Old Testament has
yeah which in turn does not have
everything that's found in the Greek
Orthodox old tested this and you look at
something like the ethiopian orthodox
church and they have a radically
different Old Testament than than the
other three the same things to be found
in terms of the New Testament
now the Protestants the Roman Catholics
and the Greek Orthodox all agree on 27
books of the New Testament but you look
at other Christian groups such as the
East Syrian or an historian Orthodox
Church they have a 22 book New Testament
they take five of the books and they say
no no we don't accept these the Coptic
Christian Church includes first and
second Clement in their New Testament
what you're not found in and the other
Bibles and again you go to the Ethiopian
Orthodox New Testament and and you find
some wildly different books the bottom
line is Christianity has never ever
agreed on what constitutes the Bible is
it true that we don't have a copy of a
copy of a copy of anything original well
we don't have anything original nothing
original no there's nothing original
what we have are typically much later
copies and you know people sometimes say
well you know there's you know p52 or
you know whatever and you know that's
very early date maybe 120 130 150 but
you know something like P 52 is a little
fragment contains like five verses maybe
or something you know so we don't have
and this is different with the Quran we
do have we we have still existent copies
of the Quran that was made under Khalif
Earth Month written
yeah this was made with him you know a
score of years the original of Prophet
Muhammad yeah
peace be upon it so is that what helped
you finally also to realize that you
know what this is a book that is not
man-made but is divinely sent certainly
the provenance of the Quran is much
better than the provenance of most of
the Bible yeah but it goes beyond
provenance historical provenance it goes
to content and when we look at the
content of the Quran you know it clears
up some things that are confusions yes
in the Bible for example for example
let's take the story of Prophet Joseph
yeah you know we're told in both the
Bible and the Quran that Prophet Joseph
had a vision in which the Sun and the
moon and and eleven stars bowed down to
him and both the Quran and and the Bible
we basically have the same
interpretation that you know his father
and mother and the eleven brothers will
bow down to him at some point in his
life yeah now the only time this could
have happened was after Joseph was sold
into slavery in Egypt by his brothers
and later rose to become the bus' ear of
Egypt and his brothers and father you
know moved to Egypt now the thing is in
the Bible were told that Joseph's mother
died giving birth to her shortly after
the birth of Benjamin the youngest boy
she would have been long dead and buried
long before Joseph was even sold into
slavery much less rose to be the Vizier
of Egypt there was no way according to
the Bible she could have ever bowed down
to it and the Quran however were told
that Joseph's parents plural came to
Egypt we don't have the story of Joseph
smothered dying yes
giving birth to Benjamin we want to
encourage people to read the verbatim
Word of God the Quran this is what you
did and you realize that this is indeed
from the creator of the heavens and
earth it's not made by men multiple men
or the Prophet peace be upon him so now
someone might say you know what this you
claim is from the crater but it's an
Arabic the original is an airbase so how
can i benefit I'm an english-speaking
first of all you have to get a good
English translation okay let me
emphasize that a good English
translation because there are some
translations out there that are not good
okay that are in fact misleading and you
want to get one that's easy to read and
there is one that has just recently come
out by rather yeah
Emmerich who's an American and a Muslim
who has translated the Koran into modern
American English yeah and this is
important what about our old us none of
that yeah no no you and not be thou
thine this is important because most
translations of the Quran that you look
at have been translated in sort of a
King James English yeah to make it sound
like the King James Bible most Americans
are not familiar with King James English
and this is true whether it's the second
and third generation of Muslims in
America or whether it's non-muslims
picking out the translation of the Quran
most of them are not familiar with King
James English they have difficulty
reading it they have difficulty
understanding it and they need something
in straightforward modern American
English and that's what the AHA
Emmerich's translation gives us but it
gives us much more now I'm holding up
the extended study edition of the Quran
is that commentary and everything this
includes sir chapter introductions it
includes the historical context in a
different font you have the historical
context of which the following verses
will reveal this is sometimes very
important in getting the proper
understanding of what the verses are
saying yeah so you have the historical
context but you also have commentary
almost 2700 footnotes worth of
commentary sometimes discussing
linguistics why something was translated
a certain way sometimes giving a saying
of the Prophet Muhammad that help
explains the text sometimes providing
other information that provides a
context to help understand the text
so the meaning of the Holy Quran in
today's English extended study edition
by brother yeah yeah Emory this is
certainly what every english-speaking
Muslim should be reading also oh
absolutely
for non-muslims either get this one or
there is another one same author called
a journey through the Holy Quran that
doesn't include all the commentary
footnotes yes
but provide you with all the rest of the
information either one and these are
available by the way in amazon.com or at
if not SIF in a.net which is brother
Umarex website let's take a break and be
right back with more here on a deed show
I solo India's Herrera solo yeah na seuk
lesson I would go to my room lock the
door go straight and class Sangha you
know me better than myself show me the
right way and I will not look that I
will leave everything behind a lot of
that greater and it creates everything
it gives encouragement to people
Mohammed is rather less innocent
back here on the Dean show and this is
what we're really trying to encourage
people to do what you did you were open
minded humble hearted you had a
connection with your Creator and you
wanted to do his will now you got a hold
of also this Quran the verbatim Word of
God and you read it we want to encourage
people to read one of the beautiful
miracles of it isn't it that it's
memorized by millions all over the world
and today you don't have different books
of the Quran it's just the one Koran
yeah there's different translations
obviously yeah and the Quran has been
translated into language after language
after language but when we really talk
about the Quran we're talking about the
Arabic original yeah and yes that's the
same there is only one version of the
Arabic now you're as American as they
get I think so so now an American who's
watching and he sees you you went to the
top university one of the top in the
world Harvard University you got your
divinity degree you were a Christian
preaching teaching the Bible eating
things giving dinner and years from a
small town and everybody knows you they
love you and now they relate they agree
look I don't want to worship Jesus I
love Jesus we love Jesus too but we say
he's not God never did he claim that he
was God this Trinity is confusing my
mind is getting a little no I'm thinking
about it it's one guy and you proved in
all of the different lectures that this
was the teaching of all the messengers
so they like what we have to say
accountability that no one's dying for
my sins I'm gonna have to be accountable
in front of God so I got to do good I
got a race for good but they you know
this whole thing now the identity the
culture huge it how did you get past it
what difficulty yes with difficulty you
know because what one does have an
identity one has a national cultural
identity in my case being an American
one also has a religious identity which
originally in my case was that of being
a Christian yes even though I was in a
typical Christian that was still the
sort of a cloak of identity that I
carried around with me in terms of my
religious identity
and it's a difficult thing to change I
did yeah it is a very difficult thing
the thing that's important I would tell
non-muslim Americans who are watching we
call them the not yet Muslim okay that's
very good to praise God you're not
giving up your national cultural
identity
you're still Muslims you're still gonna
dress in western clothing you don't have
to change your name you don't have to
take an Arabic name and by the way
that's what it is it's an Arabic name
not a Muslim name mm-hmm you don't have
to make these changes you don't have to
sit around eating bird ah
Brioni or you can still you I mean even
though you might have to go to Mik
clinic you can still look at me Donald
well if you halal McDonald a defense
where you draw the line yeah okay yeah
but sure there are certain dietary
restrictions you know we don't eat pork
we don't consume alcohol yeah
but you know aside from things like that
you keep your American national cultural
identity only change that religious
identity that's simple yeah that's and
you're doing it for the Creator the one
who loves you he created you who's the
most loving yes yes definitely okay how
could people get a hold of you if they
wanted to invite you they love you had
to say to their university to a platform
where you can speak in front of
thousands they can contact me at my
website we started with peace we on with
peace thank you very much peace be to
you brother thank you very much
and thank you again for tuning in to the
Deen show Islam which simply means to
acquire peace by submitting your will to
the One God it is growing it's the
fastest growing way of life in the world
today yesterday and tomorrow and you can
learn more about Islam here and the D
show continue to tune in every week you
can also call us if you have any further
questions and you'd like to know more 1
800 662 Islam and until next time we'll
see you peace be unto you
you